welcome back to age 20. in this section
we want to talk about
cause and effect and causality
and we do this with an example which
talks about the good guys and the bad
guys there's always good guys and bad
guys in the universe in this example
those two groups they were fighting a
war and after some very long and cooling
time
they were able to sign a peace treaty so
this happens in this story at year
number zero so in year zero a peace
treaty is signed and the good guys they
go back to their families they go back
home to their planet is a spacecraft
which is able to go with a velocity of
0.6 times the speed of light
the bad guys
are still bad guys and so they develop a
faster than the speed of light
spacecraft follow the good guys
and they succeed with the development of
the spacecraft after four years
so they do they follow the good guys
and
in year number five the bad guys attack
and destroy the good
guys so the challenge for you now is to
explain the story and answer the
following question
when and where does the attack happen
from the good guys perspective
and when did the bad guys invent the
spacecraft from the good guys
perspective and you will see
some surprising results in this another
this
so please stop the video and try to work
this out i recommend drawing a space
time diagram
in order to get to a good picture of
what is actually happening here
so if we do this you find this base time
diagram here for the bad guys so again
there's a number of important event
in year number zero
the speed the the peace treaty is is
signed and then
the good guys they start traveling away
with 0.6 times the speed of light so
what you see here is the word line of
the good
guys in year number four
in the reference frame of the bad guys
they developed their spacecraft and they
keep following
the good guys
and here in here number five
the attack actually happens
so if we analyze this for the good guys
we find that the
x position the position of the attack
is in their spacecraft so let's figure
out whether or not this is correct
we find gamma times xb
minus v
times tb
if you put in the numbers you find
luckily
the x position is equal to zero
at what time did this event happen
um here for the good guys you find gamma
times t b minus v over c x b
and again if you put the numbers in the
attack for the good guys happens in year
number four
but then the question is
when did the bad guys invent
the spacecraft in the reference frame of
the good guys and if you put in the
numbers you find the invention actually
happens
in year number five
so the attack happens before the
spacecraft is invented in the reference
frame of the good guys
and this clearly
violates
you cannot use the device which is not
even invented yet unless you
travel faster than the speed of light
you travel in time
all right i find this a really funny and
geeky example and the reason why this
doesn't work out why it's geeky is that
they travel faster than the speed of
light
so um
let me conclude this this part of this
section here with a concept question
we have an event a and ask ourselves can
event a cause other events so event a
might be the invention of a spacecraft
can event a cause event c
event d
or more than one event like b and c or b
and d
so note that the time axis here has
units years and the x-axis has units
light years
again
you know stop your video here think
about the answer maybe you draw in the
space-time diagram in order to find the
answer
and the answer is the correct answer is
c only when c can be caused because only
c
lies within what we call the light cone
of event a
in order to impact in order to cause an
effect on any other event
the message needs to be traveling
with speed
smaller than the speed of light
so that means that in order for to reach
event
c
we can you know design a spacecraft or
we can send a light beam
to this event
or to this in this direction and then
just wait a little bit
in order to make any sort of impact on
event c we cannot travel faster than the
speed of light which would be necessary
in order to reach when d
and we can also not go backwards in time
with messages in order to reach event b